Hilary Clinton wants to be
commander-in-chief and she has more
foreign policy experience than anyone
running for president
she even brags about it when she can
yeah I was very flattered when Henry
Kissinger said I ran the State
Department better that better than
anybody had run it in a long time but
she might not want a name drop a guy who
orchestrated coos propped up dictators
and probably violated international law
an experience isn't the same thing as
success what's Clinton's track record
when it comes to US intervention abroad
and why does it matter
everyone knows the back in 2002 Senator
Clinton voted for the invasion of Iraq
even though she now admits that it was a
mistake has she learned from it
well her actions at the State Department
are telling let's start with the bombing
of Libya during the Arab Spring Clinton
was the Obama administration's most
influential advocate in toppling the
Libyan dictator Muammar Gaddafi in 2011
using flawed intelligence from Libyan
opposition leaders she pressured
President Obama to join coalition forces
despite resistance from members of his
cabinet following the death of Gaddafi
NATO bombing ended but Clinton had no
strategy for securing the country after
his overthrow the chaos that followed
free-flowing weapons and armed militias
have turned Libya into a country with
competing governments no rule of law and
a growing Isis presence still the former
Secretary of State seems to be proud of
her role in regime change in Libya Libya
actually held elections they elected
moderates they have tried to piece
together a government against a lot of
really serious challenges but Libya
isn't the only case of Clinton's
militaristic approach whenever the Obama
administration was divided about using
force Clinton was on Team intervention
she repeatedly advocated for the 2009
decision to send thousands of troops to
continue the war in Afghanistan Vice
President Joe Biden and others opposed
it but even after leaving the State
Department Clinton has been vocal in her
readiness to take on conflict around the
world when it comes to Iran Clinton's
publicly supported diplomacy and the
deal
at a time when the u.s. is dropping
sanctions Clinton says there should be
new ones which is really a very
retrograde posture something that's not
shared by pretty much anyone within the
Democratic Party on Syria
Clinton's distance herself from Obama
she's called for a more aggressive
approach including a no-fly zone more
airstrikes more special ops and ground
forces actually taking back more
territory from Isis
then there's Latin America Clinton's
record points to leadership that talks a
big game on democracy but behind the
scenes isn't all that interested in it
in 2009 she condoned a coup in Honduras
even though the United Nations and
others condemned it Clinton secretly
negotiated with coup leaders to ensure
fast elections and that the former
president would not return since then
Honduras has been rife with drug
violence and police corruption it has
the highest homicide rate in the world
which is part of the reason so many
migrants have become US asylum seekers
given all that who's Clinton hoping to
attract with this record it's very
difficult to perceive who within the
Democratic primary electorate she's
trying to woo over with an extremely
hostile and antagonistic foreign policy
so is Hillary the commander-in-chief the
Democrats want and that America really
needs